[Musique]
je ne vois pas nous garde toi
quant à lui nommé dans un café du
sentier à paris quartier du sentier pas
si tu connais ces quartiers que j'aime
beaucoup parce qu'à plein de sueur sympa
il ya plein d'entreprises d'entre eux il
ya plein de code il ya les bureaux de
mon pote
ariel il ya les bureaux du journal du
geek à pas mal de monde ici est
globalement fait à gratter bon là il est
un peu tôt mais on peut acheter des
sneakers ici dans cette rue là juste là
vous avez l'agencé s'occupe des
relations presse influence ou de samsø
on peut venir voir des spectacles mais
surtout le sentier c'est le quartier
connu historiquement pour le textile
voulais pas me retrouver ici tous les
tissus sains que le quartier où avant
tout se faisait discret pour le côté
texture pouvez acheter des fringues de
tous les côtés c'est encore le cas d'un
petit peu moins mais aujourd'hui on va
pas parler textiles non aujourd'hui je
vous emmène ici à l'hôtel
exton là où va se présenter des nouveaux
smartphones et surtout le nouveau grand
lancement de swico doucement sa part le
délai des secrets ont fait venir il ya
mes vacances mais prochaine va dormir
bon très bien changer ça avait l'air
beaucoup plus gênant de la nativité
l'air beaucoup plus fatigués ouais
secrète on n'a toujours pas dit je te le
dirais pas et merci pour le secret de
monsieur bois vêtue à diffuser que des
prix en commentaire monsieur bré petite
anecdote et à hawaï
on est allé se baigner avec est donc en
fait c'est monsieur bois
la légende
est ce qu'il est bon les plus quand
j'appelle ça va ça le fait pas qu'est ce
que tu nous a piqué la écoute alors y'a
pas le produit mais on a sorti tôt
d'éclairage un éclairage des coûts oui
c'est une sorte de toi surtout un
éclairage vidéo
c'est quoi ça va fabriquer en france se
sort tout juste d'une vidéo gibbs il
préfère la bombe avec moi les gars bon
voilà là on est à l'hôtel est très bien
ici une petite gueule on à l'hôtel
exton à paris pour voir la nouvelle
collection de oui comme ça vous savez à
coucou ça va être le mec qui devrait
dans la vidéo et qui derrière qui fait
jusqu'au cou pour vous présenter deux
nouveaux smartphones on a deux oui qu
est donc ici l'on aurait dû les voir
normalement à barcelone mais vous savez
qu'à cause du coronavirus et bien le mwc
est annulé pas de popol nuls cela moi je
me dis voilà donc les deux nouveaux
smartphones que wilko devait nous
présenter appartenait qu'on va du coup
d'ici à paris il ya celui là ça c'est le
view 4 il ya son petit frère qui est le
view 4 life j'aurais pu m'attendre à ce
qui est un vieux quatre pros il y aura
pas de yucca de produire un vieux 4 plus
au mois de juin et oublie qu'on nous
annonce effectivement il n'allait pas
faire des tarifs plus de un peu moins de
200 euros pour pas se mettre en
concurrence avec d'autres acteurs du
marché qui pourrait leur faire du mal et
du coup qui ferait que les produits ne
se rendraient pas s'est un petit peu
l'idée globale voilà donc on a ces deux
nouveaux smartphones sont morts parce
qu'on oublie qu'on a vraiment fait un
très gros focus en parlant de la
batterie la batterie la batterie la
batterie la batterie view 4 batteries de
5000 heure par heure on nous annonce une
autonomie jusqu'à trois jours pour que
pourquoi pas à tester bien évidemment et
sur le view 4 lite on nous annonce une
autonomie allant jusqu'à deux jours avec
une batterie de 4000 milles et
antérieurs alors c'est vrai parce que
nous faut un gros focus en disant nous
ce que veulent nos
nous usagers c'est effectivement des
smartphones qui vont loin qui dure qui
vont longtemps où on a toujours la
batterie on n'en pas ok ça c'est plutôt
pas mal par contre ça aurait été bien
d'avoir des écrans full hd
on a l'âge des plus ici peut-être un
petit peu le truc qui va manquer je
comprends qu'on veuille un smartphone
qui dure longtemps et ça c'est plutôt
cool et c'est vraiment très très bon
point de la part de micro mais moi ce
que j'aime beaucoup sur un smartphone
c'est d'abord la meilleure qualité
d'affichage genre on peut pas tout avoir
à tous les primo faire des choix
forcément aux danseurs des smartphones à
moins de 200 euros
il faut faire quelques coûte bon voilà
ça c'est un peu peut-être un point de
regret à avoir un faut le tester pour
bien se rendre compte à l'usagé on à
être des écrans de 6 52 pouces que vous
soyez sur le view 4 ou sur le view 4
light avec une définition en hd plus
c'est à dire c'est du 720 pixels on va
pas monter en 1920 par 1080 ici non on
ne l'aura pas on sera un petit peu en
dessous bon avoir des évidements il faut
voir comment les dalles sont calibrés
faut voir si elles sont intéressantes ça
je pouvoir loin effectivement lors du
test d'ici quelques temps donc si c'est
pas le cas je t'invite dès maintenant à
vous abonner et puisqu'on parle de ça je
t'invite à mener c'est aussi des jolies
pouce parce que bien évidemment
algorithmes faisant il faut se
référencer il faut des pouces donc on
met des pistes humides et pousse aussi
en mai 2008 jour mais tous mes pouces
mettez les posies pas commentaire
partagé la vidéo
la petite voix j'adore le vélo sur
instagram voilà et nous mais moins sur
instagram voilà suivait nous tous
envoyez-nous de l'amour ensuite on va se
retrouver ici récupérer un triple module
photo alors soit vous pouvez pas louper
il est juste ici vous avez donc un
triple capteur photo
la caméra que vous avez là parce que
c'est celle du bassin 13 mégapixels
on n'a pas d'info sur l'ouverture on
sait qu'elle est boosté à l'intelligence
artificielle c'est la reconnaissance de
scène c'est un petit peu standard c'est
ce qu'on retrouve mais ça permettra
vraiment d'optimiser vos photos en un
deuxième capteur de 5 mégapixels c'est
celui qui lie à au milieu la regarde
elle qui est là pour avoir un ultra
grand angle à 180 degrés vous êtes à
l'extérieur il faut beaucoup de lumière
ainsi apple beaucoup de lumière les
ultras qu'en tant que c'est pas terrible
vous mettez donc à l'extérieur vous les
shoots un bâtiment paf vous manqué un
petit peu de plans d'ouverture et bien
vous mettez votre ultra grand-angle et
vous l'avez dans le champ pourquoi pas
ça peut être rigolo à voir à tester
également est au dessus juste là bien
d'elle
ici vous avez une caméra de 2 mégapixels
qui est là pour le mode portrait pour
les faits de bric et vous apporter le
flou d'arrière-plan ça c'est un grand
standard vous avez à l'avant ici une
toute petite caméra sur le vu quatre
attelages règlement dette il faut qu'on
reste patente voilà ici une caméra de 8
mégapixels ça c'est pour la caméra de
celle fille une fois de plus aucune info
sur l'ouverture et sur le vieux 4
vous avez exactement le même module
photo à l'arrière que sur le vieux 4 et
à la banque vous avez une caméra de 5
mégapixels envie d'avoir une caméra de 8
mégapixels
dans les deux cas vous tournez avec le
processeur de médiathèque le à 25 sur le
view 4 vous avez 3 giga drame puisque
sur le view 4 lite vous avez deux gigas
drame
on a le même processeur ma peau moindre
un peu moins de fluidité sur le modèle
lie ce qui n'est pas anormal s'est mis à
faire des coupes vu qu'on a le même
module photo vu qu'on a le même
processeur la coupe elle se fait au
niveau de la ram vous avez sur le vieux
4 64 giga de ram extensible jusqu'à 256
galicie 32 gigas de ram son modèle light
extensible à 256 giga également grâce à
une carte microsd
les deux tourne sur un android 10 ayez
une petite nouveauté qui a été apportée
de petites nouveautés je crois que ce
bouton là c'est un petit bouton pour
appeler google assistant vous êtes
l'attaquent vous allez smartphone à la
main au lieu de faire ok google tout va
déclencher ces jolies trop fort vous
appuyez sur le bouton google assistant
arrive vous lui posez vos questions
bon je sais pas si avec grand intérêt
d'ajouter un bouton physique et si ce
n'est pas ce que puisque vous avez une
commande vocale peut-être que si vous
êtes dans un lieu où vous ne peut pas
parler trop fort couchot teklak vous
appuyez vous lui parlez dans le creux de
l'oreille
peut-être je suis pas sûr lusage mais
bon pourquoi pas par contre qu'on lui
connaît et il a su ces cas le capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui a été retiré
parce qu'ils considèrent que la
reconnaissance faciale sera plus
utilisée et que ça fonctionnera est ce
que c'est juste aussi pour gagner en
termes de coût à mon avis est plus là
dessus que se tient le la vérité et je
crois qu'on a à peu près tout dit
vouloir les couleurs à huy les couleurs
merci diop les couleurs les scènes où
tous les couleurs elles sont là voilà
merci merci nous sommes sur le vieux 4
on a donc
bleu or et vert il appelle sac cosmique
fait parce que vous avez un côté
brouillon tout simplement apprendre à se
remettre comme ça voilà ça c'est le
cosmic parce que c'est brillant donc
vous l'avez en bleu en verre et en or
tandis que sur le modèle lite vous êtes
en maths et ils nous l'ont fait ça
comment ils vous appelez ça dip
voilà le mat ses jeeps et on l'a en bleu
vert or également de la même manière
donc en gros soit vous avez un
smartphone qui brille et qui prend les
reflets soit vous avez un smartphone
maths qui prendra moins les traces de
doigts celui apprendra davantage mais
bon il faut aussi son petit effet voilà
un petit peu pour l'idée les formats ça
se tient comme en bas c'est que c'est
quasiment la même chose
qu'est ce qui t'arrive à les accessoires
et les accessoires
désormais je sois oui c'est quoi ça
c'est l'ensemble ça c'est la petite
enceinte petites enceintes rico que tu
peux séparé en deux par ce centre bourg
et du stéréo et ça fait du stéréo comme
ça que mes maîtres comme sortie de sa
part à fond je deviens complètement sosa
c'est la nouveauté c'est la petite
enceinte l'icône sortie aussi des petits
écouteurs trueye en laisse il ya deux
modèles sans les verra qui sortiront
plus tard on verra si on n'en pas
d'ailleurs si vous voulez qu'on en parle
dans quelques mois tout de suite en bas
en commentaire je ne suis curieux de
voir ce que ça donne mais je sais pas si
c'est les points qui vont beaucoup de
gens parce qu'on a un marché très
compliqué les écouteurs trouvailles en
laisse
il y en a partout toutes les marques en
sorte ne sais pas si les consommateurs
attendent des ricoh en tout cas là
dessus à voir est ce que en dix ans
j'achète mon view 4 tuant moche mais
j'écoute alors ça peut avoir un sens je
sais pas il faut voir comment ces
calculs et j'aimais je me demande d
offres d offre de lancement de combos
c'est ça qui peut faire un peu
l'histoire parce que sinon j'ai un peu
de mal à y croire alors sinon on va
décoller quand même les tarifs se view 4
il coûte la modique somme de 169 euros
il sera dispo en mars 2001 c'est à dire
demain quasiment quelque chose près et
le view 4 lights 129 euros en avril il
faudra attendre un petit mois de plus si
je vous dis au mois de juin devrait voir
arriver le view 4 plus qui sera un
modèle un peu plus haut de gamme qui
devrait coûter fans et autres tout deal
devrait devrait pas être au dessus des
199 euros voilà un peu pour cette
nouvelle gamme de wiko 2020
très déçu de pas être à barcelone mais
très content de voir ces produits de
voir que wilko est toujours présent
toujours là avec des produits qui
restent dans leur adn ou salés ou nikos
est une marque sur les produits pour les
millénium c'est l'idée c'est d'avoir une
cible un peu plus jeunes si une marque a
depuis neuf ans
c'est une marque qui se ressentent sur
de gamme la gamme view que vous avez ici
et puis la gamme y y et la gamme je
dirais la moins chère donc voilà un peu
pour c'est la grande nouveauté du côté
turc ou dites moi si ça vous intéresse
nous ce que vous en pensez vous à
première vue de ses modèles le view 4
light et le view 4 4 4 4
voilà sur ce on fait des bisous fait des
bises - fred & farid ou une vidéo il est
évident ces divisions quoi ont besoin de
l'amour voilà
et envoyez-nous de l'amour mettez nous
des coeurs en bas en commentaire à
demain bisous ciao
non
ces bolides abonnés
monde